comment le parti islamiste ennahda at-il
pu remporter la victoire en tunisie le
parti nahd constitue une menace pour les
libertés et pour l'intégration de la
tunisie dans le monde extérieur de la
chute de ben ali le 14 janvier
aux élections du 23 octobre le
documentaire tunisie a les héros revient
sur les premiers mois de la nouvelle
tunisie
entre espoirs et déceptions tunisie
année 0 lundi à 22h30 sur public sénat
la nouvelle majorité sénatoriale a pris
possession du palet de marie de médicis
moi j'avais le sentiment ce soir là
qu'ils ont pris la bastille
nos amis sénateurs de l'ump n'accepte
pas bien l'idée que le sénat changent et
que ils ne sont plus majoritaires
un sénat à gauche pour la première fois
de son histoire un virage qui vient
bouleverser l'examen du budget texte
phare de l'année en repoussant le débat
sur la loi de finances vous vous asseyez
lourdement sur la constitution vous
privilégiez votre démagogie
électoraliste au détriment de l'intérêt
collectif au service des français
vous ne pouvez pas prétendre empêché à
toute force à chaque fois la majorité
d'aller jusqu'au vote
conséquence de l'alternance la gauche
obtient le poste de rapporteur du budget
une première en général non la mesure
que proposera le gouvernement dans la
loi de finances rectificative n'est pas
aussi juste que celle que je propose
mais les socialistes laissent à
l'opposition ump la présidence de la
commission des finances
une décision controversée qui va changer
la donne vous auriez tort de mépriser ce
qu'ils ont fait sincèrement parce
contraints de travailler ensemble les
deux nouveaux protagonistes sont des
habitués mais leur rôle ont radicalement
changé
difficile de l'arrêter nicole bricq
toute la journée elles courent pas une
vedette de cinéma moindre je suis pas
bankable en vie c'est la première femme
à occuper le poste de rapporteur du
budget jamais eu mes fonctions parce que
j'étais une femme à ben les é-u part
parce que je sais ce que je fais je ne
fais pas partie d'une génération où
montanes et man ont été une femme même
si elle avait un beau sourire et s'est
du coup quand même merci historique
oui on n'exagérons pas
dans le bureau qu'elle occupe depuis le
mois d'octobre
nicole bricq n'a presque rien changé je
travaillerai dans un couloir
non non je fais pas attention sur dur
que qu'une fonction à la seule chose que
j'ai changé le tableau bon j'ai pris
dans le fond de la maison voilà ils ont
nettoyé les moquettes les murs mais bon
il n'y aurait pas faisable
le projet né voilà qui suffit à camper
le personnage c'est une bosseuse elle
déjeune souvent dans son bureau en
consultant ses dossiers
ça prend du temps je pars tous les soirs
avec le pack est un peu la bouche
partition troubleront j'étais une
provinciale au départ à une époque où
c'était pas rien je parle de gt pas une
énarque donc je n'avais pas le réseau
j'étais d'un milieu qui n'était pas figé
pas filles 2 je me suis toujours battu
pour qu'à un moment donné on dise bas
c'est elle voilà reitman nous aura
épaisse
député puis sénatrice en 2004 d'une
assemblée à l'autre nicole bricq a
toujours été membre de la commission des
finances
alors devenir rapporteur du budget elle
ya pensé plus d'une fois et hasard ou
pas pour les élus socialistes sa
candidature n'a pas fait l'ombre d'un
doute ne nous a pas tant sénat a voté
les recettes avant liesse de commencer à
les défenses et philippe marini
c'est lui le prédécesseur de nicole
bricq il a cédé son fauteuil de
rapporteur contre celui de président son
nouveau bureau est au premier étage
juste au-dessous de l'ancien quand je
rentre de séance
machinalement je vais vers l'ascenseur
et j'étais j'appuie sur le bouton 2 et
puis tout d'un coup je me rends compte
ça c'est le réflexe conditionné vous
savez présent avoir occupé les mêmes
lieux sacrés nécessairement d habitude
il disait attendre avec gourmandise
d'être dans l'opposition mais s'est
doucement qu'ils s'habituent à son
nouveau rôle je me sens moins
opérationnel vous voyez celui qui donne
le ton de la discussion budgétaire le
leader de la discussion budgétaire celle
rapporteur général pas très confortable
de diriger une commission à majorité de
gauche
alors fini le traditionnel devoir de
réserve du président depuis octobre les
interviews s'enchaînent je le fais
couramment à la demande de journalistes
ou parfois en les sollicitant quand je
pense qu'il y a des messages à
transmettre
la gauche le jugent trop libéral et
aurait préféré voir un autre sénateur de
l'opposition à sa place certains
pointent ses conflits d'intérêts nicole
bricq elle-même lépingle dans un rapport
sur la cession de l'hippodrome de
compiègne ville dont il est le maire
celle avec ils forment aujourd'hui un
improbable temps d'un petit déjeuner de
presse annuelle de la commission des
finances les journalistes découvrent les
deux nouveaux patrons du budget au sénat
leur première apparition publique
ensemble comme le veut la tradition
c'est le président qui s'exprime en
premier
il est évident qu'entre nicole bricq et
moi même nous n'avons pas exactement la
même idée de l'avenir peut-on imaginer
que le gouvernement de la législature
sortante soit email
peut-on se borner à critiquer toutes ces
initiatives
on ne va pas
sauver un gouvernement qui est quand
même à votre course qui a permis quand
même tous ses repères il y en a un qui
est quand même
vous n'aimez pas qu'on le rappelle
monsieur le président mais quand on
regarde les chiffres 2011 rien tous
viacom année sur deux années 28
milliards de prélèvements obligatoires
donc sa route la présentation du budget
se termine la pratique veut que le
président laisse le rapporteur seul avec
la presse philippe marini est priée de
s'éclipser vous dévoile à devoir
m'appelle et le voit aujourd'hui
concrètement est ce que ça veut dire que
vous allez déposer des amendements sur
rétablissement ou un renforcement de
d'heuliez fait ça c'est le débat de la
présidentielle
moi je pense que je prépare ce débat
mais serait même moi personnellement
pour aller au bout
ce jour là nicole bricq nom dira pas
plus sur le contenu de ses amendements
mais le ton est donné
j'espère présidence
la victoire les a surpris mais très vite
les sénateurs socialistes réalise le
pouvoir de faire passer les textes c'est
eux qui l'ont désormais doit se défaire
un petit peu de cette pratique
d'opposants et être soucieux de d'être
dans une logique d'ensemble
le groupe socialiste décide des
amendements qui seront mis au vote en
commission
chaque sénateur peut-on proposer mais
tous ne sont pas retenus on enlève être
majoritaire implique un changement de
méthode ne plus se disperser pour faire
en sorte que la gauche communiste et
verts compris s'expriment d'une seule
voix ce qui implique de proposer moins
d'amendements qu'avant
problème de principe de transférer un
crédit d'impôt à des ayants droit est un
cousin séquences et qui paye oui mais le
problème c'est que il ya des contacts
mais la dame de compagnie
l'électricien dynegy d'entre elles qui
permettent à gries mission identique ou
inférieur une science publie plaisant de
prestige fait le reste
on peut léser unipol dira dans son avis
sur ma maman est fan des convictions et
une compétence et un caractère bien
trempé oui je pense que c'est aussi pour
cela qu'elle remplit bien sa mission
où
nicole bricq arrive en commission des
finances
il est 9h30 l'heure de commencer
le président est en retard
à
m
alors maintenant me le rapporteur
général sur le plan quantitatif est ce
que c'est un est ce que c'est
je ne vais pas dire un grand cru mais
est ce que c'est un cru à bandes en
voilà
c'est un coût raisonnable et je pense
que ce sera un bon cru
ça ne dépend que de nous c'est ici que
sont votées les amendements déposés par
les différents groupes avant leur
discussion en séance
là aussi l'ambiance de travail a bien
changé non non non je te rappelle même
donc et l'imposition à 19% des plus
values à long terme sur titres de
participation c'est la proposition que
nous le fait on n'y aura plus que
bizarre il pose un problème de de
cohérence
parce qu'il impose à 19% les plus-values
sur les types de placements sa superbe
désormais les discussions techniques
laissent plus souvent place au débat
d'idées exemple quand la gauche demande
la fin de l'allègement des droits de
succession suit
c'est connu et je le revendique contre
l'héritage donc tous deux ans mais je
vois la responsabilité
pour cet amendement s'il est accepté
avec des catégories qui sont dans les
plus faibles catégories de revenus avec
l'alternance le rapport de force s'est
inversé
ceux qui hier avait le budget en main
doivent aujourd'hui s'opposer c'est une
colle intéressante pour les nerfs
l'intelligence tout le reste nous sommes
bien dans loin
jamais en
philippe marini retrouve les maires de
son département il est accueilli en
gardien du temple ump et on présente
comme le pouvoir en place et bien que
l'on pense pas tout et n'importe quoi
avant de commencer le niveau de la jambe
dans l'opposition je veux être président
d'une commission dont on n'a pas la
majorité l'opposition au gouvernement
c
de la lave
pas forcément très lyrique
continuer à être visible en étant
opposant un nouveau défi pour philippe
marini
c'est un peu comme entrer en résistance
car oui mais on
et après tu es rattrap et à l'assemblée
nationale dakar est rattrapé les aubes
écouter les socialistes il apprend
l'opposition ça lui fait beaucoup de
bien moi qui était son opposante au
conseil municipal pendant des années je
me suis fait beaucoup de bien
d'apprendre la minorité
après 60 ans passés dans la majorité au
sénat la droite cherche ses marques
être dans l'opposition c'est pour eux
une première les ump se retrouvent pour
discuter de la stratégie à adopter
nous sommes des commissaires aux
finances
on a décidé d'accorder nos violons ne
pas en parler
dressons sans avoir eu nombre de
conduite commune mais sous la houlette
de notre président marine et qui est le
plus expert de tout ça donc c'est pas
mal quand même
c'est une discipline collective que nous
nous sommes donnés cela fait c'est
seconde réunion de ce type que nous
faisons toutes les deux semaines toutes
les trois semaines
salon très régulièrement partager nos
nos sentiments et et décider de la
manière dont nous nous comporterons en
commission en séance sur les sujets qui
sont de notre compétence nous sommes
dans une situation nouvelle alors il
faut que nous réagissions en agissant il
s'agit bien là de motiver les troupes
pour que l'ump soit active merci
retour en commission des finances
le vote sur les amendements de nicole
bricq se poursuit
le premier ministre vient d'annoncer un
nouveau plan de rigueur
nous avons tous bien entendu les
annonces qui a fait le premier ministre
et quand on appelle maintenant le plan
fillon de ce lundi dernier et nous
constatons tous ça c'est tout à fait
objectif que il ne remet pas en cause
les dispositifs coûteux du plan tepa de
l'été 2007 comme la droite ne le fait
pas c'est elle qui va s'en charger
combattre la loi tepa ce symbole du
sarkozysme
ce budget 2012 c'est l'occasion rêvée
pour nicole bricq de faire le bilan du
quinquennat qui s'achève ainsi la gauche
met fin à ce qu'il reste du bouclier
fiscal
en supprimant l'exonération des heures
supplémentaires ramène à 10000 euros par
foyer
le plafond des niches fiscales et créer
une tranche d'impôt supplémentaire sur
le revenu à 45%
c'est pas dans les six mois qui
précèdent une élection présidentielle
que par des petites mesures on va se
fait à déstabiliser le l'économie de
notre pays est par ailleurs certaines
mesures de rigueur du gouvernement sont
aussi supprimés comme la taxe sur les
boissons sucrées ou la hausse de la tva
avant moi je voudrais quand même
souligner que ce cet amendement c'est du
pur affichage et moi je veux je trouve
que c'est extrêmement grave
chacun fait ses propositions dire que
c'est pas sérieux c'est quelque part
injurieux moi je vais pas accepter ça
les deux énormes bon donc la commission
et et éclairé alors qu'ils souhaitent
s'opposer qui soit vous votez pour
pardon pardon réclusion en faire prendre
des rues alors dit prêt 14e présente dit
pouvoir fait 24 de l'autre côté à la fin
de l'exercice ce qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui
oui on fera les additions et des
soustractions on le voit là on a gagné
des milliards d'euros le veut plus tout
à l'heure mais dans des conditions dans
des conditions qui n'ont le ce côté ci
ne paraissent pas acceptables mais c'est
que c'est votre responsabilité
nicole bricq ou un autre elle
expérimente ses fonctions bon elle et
elle et elle est encore un peu raide
c'est un peu son tempérament aussi
parfois vous savez d'ailleurs les gens
qui sont bourru ou raides il ya beaucoup
de sensibilité dessous
cela peut arriver mais je pense qu'avec
quelques années de pratique
tout cela va s'atténuer il déploie une
certaine habilité
c'est un président très politique tract
politique
nicole bricq avait prévenu la discussion
budgétaire se fera projet contre projet
une certaine manière moi j'ai clair
l'avenir mais surtout j'essaie aussi
c'est le boulot du rapporteur général il
ya que lui ou elle en l'occurrence qui
peut le faire de faire aussi une
certaine pédagogie
la gauche veut montrer qu'en pleine
crise elle peut faire des économies mais
qu'avec elle ce ne sont plus les mêmes
qui payent en séance le face à face
entre la rapporteure et la ministre du
budget tourne à l'affrontement
vous savez que le paquet tepa coûtent
encore aux finances de la france 9
milliards 300 millions d'euros chaque
année
donc si vous aviez voulu vraiment
réduire le déficit vous auriez emprunté
beaucoup plus fermement la voie que nous
avons ouvert votre projet c'est la
récession programmée car au moment où la
croissance mondiale ralentit vous avez
choisi d'augmenter de 20 milliards
d'euros la fiscalité sur les entreprises
ce qui représente une hausse de près de
50% de l'impôt sur les sociétés en un an
il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de politique
économique alternative à celle du
gouvernement il n'y a pas d'alternative
à la politique de réduction de déficit
et d'économies budgétaires
je ne me situerais pas sur le même
registre que madame la ministre
j'ai quelques années politique de plus
qu'elle est donc je sais faire la
différence entre qu'on peut dire à la
tribune d'un meeting d'un quand est ce
qu'on doit dire devant la représentation
nationale
cette simple très vite le débat
budgétaire est détournée l'hémicycle du
sénat
peu habituée aux éclats de voix se
transforme en tribune politique
oui de la crédibilité et ben oui donne
parti qui cherche à rassembler la gauche
pour espérer gouverner la france et qui
apparaît désuni en interne mais aussi
avec ses partenaires politiques
potentielles sur nombre de sujets de
fond les errements et les
tergiversations d'eva joly l'illustrent
d'ailleurs parfaitement sur le fond sur
le fond le seul avantage dans sénat à
gauche et de permettre mes chers
collègues d'apprécier ce qui attendrait
les français si vous arriviez au pouvoir
en 2012
permettez moi de vous dire mes remèdes
je crois que le vrai visage de françois
hollande il se montre aussi au sénat
plus de dépenses plus de taxes c'est le
sénat dans l'opposition c'est la
socialite le nom est lâché
pour la droite le sénat est devenue la
maison des hollandais
rapporteur du budget une fonction qui
expose surtout quand on s'attaque à la
loi de finances du gouvernement
ces journalistes prépare un documentaire
sur les propositions des candidats à la
présidentielle et les choix de nicole
bricq au sénat les intéressent lang et
jean important électrique pour les
représenter à vous parce que voilà ce
qui va se passer jargon qui vient après
nous sommes il paraît que les gens qui
vont avoir un rôle à jouer dans l'avenir
groupe open in france hollande est
candidat
françois hollande c'est son candidat
elle ne s'en cache pas n'avons rien fait
qui puisse être contradictoire avec ce
que le candidat à la présidentielle des
socialistes notre françois hollande
pourrait proposer rien ne peut le gêner
dans les propositions que nous faisons
je rappelle que quand même
j'ai des propositions qu'on fait quand
même depuis plusieurs années tout se
fait en coordination avec l'équipe de
holland dans l'ombre
nicole bricq prépare 2012
elle participe aux réunions organisées
en toute discrétion à l'assemblée
nationale par les proches du candidat
derrière cette porte se prépare le
programme socialiste à la présidentielle
au fil des jours le ton se durcit à
l'ump
la majorité fait courir un risque à la
crise
la droite est en colère et convoque la
presse pour le dire pour dénoncer un
sénat transformé selon lui en
laboratoire du projet socialiste
nous avons ici des socialistes
irresponsables et d'autant plus
irresponsable que c'est irresponsable et
pas coupable
donc on assiste une espèce de déferlante
idéologique il n'a pas grand chose à
voir avec les réalités
il s'y croit déjà leur première
préoccupation c'est de régler des
comptes avec ce que nous allons faire
notamment en 2007
le vrai but de cette riposte montrer que
la droite sénatoriale n'est plus sonné
par la défaite qu'elle s'est ressaisi et
qu'en cette période électorale le
gouvernement peut compter sur elle
j'ai dit au président de la réserve
fédérale gestion qu'on me dise pas ce
que tu sais c'est l'assemblée nationale
aucun doute c'est aussi au sénat que se
joue la campagne présidentielle le jour
du vote du budget martine aubry s'invite
au palais elle est accueillie par
françois rebsamen président du groupe
socialiste
je travaillais confrères
commission des finances a plané
camara si on écoutait ce qu'on fait le
sénat aujourd'hui c'est à dire réduire
les niches fiscales réduire des cadeaux
fiscaux d'éviter une politique
d'austérité aussi forte qu'on le
président a un public qui est en train
de la mettre en place et qui va nous
conduire à la catastrophe
donc le sénat n'a pas besoin d'être
galvanisé il l'est déjà et au soutien
parce que dans le fond c'est un peu là
l'avancé au soutien de ce que notre
candidat françois hollande défunt et
montrer qu'effectivement ce que l'on
fait ici c'est ce que la gauche veut
faire quand françois hollande serait élu
président la république
voilà qui est dit avec la bataille
budgétaire la gauche s'offre une vitrine
idéale et c'est désormais assumer
l'effervescence dans la salle on dit
long tous sont là pour écouter les
félicitations de la patronne du ps l'a
reconnu que c'était très important le
travail qu'on avait faits et surtout que
sur l'essentiel on a montré une autre
voie était possible
ces enfants
l'après midi
nicole bricq arrive en séance avec le
sourire c'est une étape importante
c'est le vote la première fois que la
gauche va voter son budget donc c'est
important pour elle et pour moi c'est
l'heure vous venez pas si mal et folle
on va aller écouter dans ce cas on fait
avant le dîner non non non c'est bien
paramétrer des choses je citais pour la
première fois depuis longtemps je vais
voter contre le budget vous voyez et
finalement ça fait du bien de voter
contre
je vous ai sur un parce qu'on se libère
on exprime ses insatisfactions ces refus
ses indignations
la séance est ouverte
le sénat va procéder au vote sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi de
financement
madame borique après 20 jours de débats
la gauche au sénat mais au vote
son premier budget pour l'adoption 175
contre 168
le sénat a adopté la majorité vote 11
milliards d'euros de recettes ensemble
ump centre dénonce une parodie de budget
pour eux la gauche ne fait que créer de
nouvelles taxes
nous nous sommes livrés mes chers
collègues à un pur exercice de science
fiction qu aucune agence de notation
n'aurait pu imaginer et je regrette
amèrement que nous tendions à devenir le
lieu d'une mascarade généralisée
contraire à l'esprit qui préside au bon
fonctionnement de nos institutions et de
la république
c'est une victoire pour nicole bricq
mais elle sait que son contre budget ne
passera pas les portes du sénat
le marathon budgétaire s'achève à
l'assemblée
les sénateurs arrivent pour la
commission mixte paritaire
le but est de trouver à huis clos un
compromis entre les deux chambres
compte tenu des choix fisc ont fait par
la majorité sénatoriale gens absolument
incompatible avec la vision du
gouvernement et de la majorité de
l'assemblée nationale la réunion
n'aboutit à aucun accord à l'assemblée
la droite est majoritaire
c'est elle qui a le dernier mot à son
tour elle va remanier le budget pour
revenir à la version du gouvernement
évidemment la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale suit son gouvernement et évite
de parler de sujets qui fâchent mais
craignais que leurs positions face les
français tous ses amendements politiques
sont rejetés mais qu'importe
pour nicole bricq il s'agissait d'
éclairer les enjeux de 2012
le message est passé et c'est ça qui
compte
non
bonsoir et merci d'être entre compagnies
ce soir les trois thèmes de cette
campagne 2012 seront la crise la crise
et enfin la crise que la politique ce
n'est pas la guerre civile a donc dit
xavier bertrand
parler de ce printemps du jasmin
sa victoire si elle est vérifiée demain
puisqu'il surprenante
comment vous jugez son action dans cette
tempête
quelle époque on avait tous ri
aujourd'hui on rit moins votre rendez
vous quotidien avec l'information c'est
du lundi au jeudi à 22h sur public sénat
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition d'en quête d'europe
au menu de cette émission retour sur les
grands dossiers qui ont fait l'actualité
européenne
nous irons tout d'abord en allemagne un
pays en cruel manque de main d'oeuvre
qui fait appel aux jeunes diplômés des
pays en crise nous reviendrons ensuite
sur la crise qui a frappé les
agriculteurs français en guerre avec
leurs homologues espagnols
enfin direction la hongrie quelques mois
après le passage des boues rouges
toxiques à kolontar comment ce village
s'est il reconstruit mais d'abord on
part en italie à la rencontre de cette
génération perdue qui a du mal à entrer
dans la vie active alors fera pourquoi
parle-t-on de génération perdue en
italie en fait on parle de génération
perdue parce qu'il est très difficile
aujourd'hui d'être un jeune en italie ce
sont les premières victimes de la crise
économique qui touche ce pays
aujourd'hui est très difficile de
trouver un emploi stable c'est un
véritable parcours du combattant et les
chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes 60 % des
18-34 ans vivent encore chez leurs
parents et ce chiffre a triplé depuis
les années 80 tout simplement parce
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à trouver un
emploi et donc à avoir des revenus
réguliers pour pouvoir se permettre de
payer un loyer et de quitter donc leurs
parents et qui est effectivement le
cocon familial
donc là on vous suit direction rome où
vous avez été rencontrés d'urbana tessin
à 30 ans giovan à un master en
traduction et un doctorat d'anglais et
d'espagnol
malgré ses diplômes elle peine à trouver
un emploi stable comme beaucoup de
jeunes italiens de sa génération
pour gagner sa vie elle cumule les
contrats précaires et elle donne des
cours particuliers
alors on va commencer le cours
d'espagnol en parallèle des cours
particuliers giovanna un contrat de
projet de 20 heures par semaine dans une
école maternelle un contrat à temps
partiel d'octobre à mai cette jeune
italienne à un but dans la vie obtenir
un cdi
un objectif qui lui semble quasi
inaccessible mon rêve serait de trouver
un travail stable un type de contrat qui
ne garantissent plus de sécurité
le rêve absolu ce serait de trouver un
contrat à durée déterminée ça semble
peut-être dérisoire mais ce n'est pas
une chose facile à trouver
les seules personnes que je connais qui
ont un contrat à durée indéterminée soit
ils sont plus âgés que moi
ils ont sept huit ans de plus que moi et
ils ont eu pendant plus de 15 ans un
emploi précaire soit ils ont passé un
concours d'état pour devenir
fonctionnaire
comme deux tiers des jeunes italiens de
chevannes habite encore chez ses parents
à rome avec 800 euros par mois en
moyenne difficile de quitter le cocon
familial
ça me plairait d'avoir un appartement à
moi d'avoir mon autonomie
ce n'est pas facile de trouver un
logement avec un emploi comme le mien
car un emploi précaire comme le mien ne
me permet pas de payer un loyer mais cet
ovale de ballons et les parents de
giovanna sont très préoccupés par
l'avenir de leur fille dans lost et
l'histoire d'hier fat malgré les études
qu'elle a fait
le master le dr à des études
universitaires qui aurait dû lui
faciliter son entrée sur le marché du
travail
la réponse n'est pas là tempo passe
aujourd'hui giovanna à 30 ans le temps
passe et elle est obligée de se
contenter de contrats de projets qui ne
correspondent absolument pas aux études
qu'elle a fait la situation de giovanna
est loin d'être exceptionnelle pier
luigi cheli l'une des figures du système
éducatif en italie vient de publier un
ouvrage dans lequel il incite son fils
jeunes diplômés à quitter le pays
son livre a suscité le débat en italie
les jeunes qui sortent de l'université
avec de bons diplômes ne trouvent pas de
travail dans ce pays où les conditions
économiques sont très difficiles il
préfère partir à l'étranger et en
général ils ne reviennent pas autre
problème la culture du piston elle est
tellement ancrée en italie qu'il est
difficile pour un jeune qui sort de
l'université de trouver un travail
uniquement grâce à ses diplômes l'unique
moyen d'obtenir un travail dans ce pays
est soit de connaître quelqu'un soit de
devenir le porteur d'eau d'un politique
c'est tout un système où ce qui compte
ce n'est pas ce que l'on sait faire mais
ce que l'on est prête à faire pour
obtenir un emploi
et la crise économique a aggravé les
choses l'italie a le triste record
d'europe du taux de chômage des jeunes
depuis la crise 80 % des suppressions
d'emplois recensés dans le pays ont
concerné les 18 29 ans à la fin de
l'année 2009
il y avait deux millions de jeunes qui
non seulement n'étudier pas mais qui ne
travaillait pas non plus c'est un
chiffre particulièrement important et
cette situation a des répercussions sur
le taux de natalité
d'autant qu'en italie le salaire minimum
et les allocations familiales n'existe
pas on en est à 1,4 enfant par femme
c'est un problème très grave pour
l'italie dans notre pays
le climat social on n'encourage pas
vraiment à faire des enfants
pl viau et alessia sont tous les deux
précaires ils s'investissent aux
jeunesses communistes pour essayer de
faire bouger les choses et ils ont fait
de la lutte contre la précarité des
jeunes un combat de tous les jours
d'avoir un contrat d'un jour en semaine
à moi mais c'est très très difficile
qu'un jour quand j'aime aujourd'hui à un
contrat attend un bébé n'est exclue
d'une société dont ils dénoncent l'
individualisme des jeunes italiens n'ont
d'autre avenir que la précarité ou
l'exil
alors florac comment expliquez-vous la
difficulté de ces jeunes à intégrer le
marché du travail sous l'ère berlusconi
on à flexibiliser le marché du travail
en 1997 il ya une série de réformes qui
avait pour objectif de flexibiliser le
marché du travail réforme qui a été
accentuée par la loi 30 en 2003 qui a
créé un certain nombre de contrats de
travail qui conduisent finalement à
l'enterrement la mort du cdi
est ce qu'il ya de l'espoir encore pour
ces jeunes là alors c'est vrai qu' il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'espoir quand on
voit le nombre d'italiens de jeunes
italiens qui sont contraints et forcés a
émigré à l'étranger pour avoir un emploi
stable
on se dit que l'avenir n'est pas rose
pour les jeunes italiens aujourd'hui il
ya un certain nombre d'italiens comme
des jeunes espagnols comme des jeunes
portugais qui sont obligés d'aller à
l'étranger au royaume uni en france en
allemagne pour essayer d'obtenir un
emploi stable un cdi
merci flora à l'instar des jeunes
italiens les jeunes grecs et espagnols
sont aussi contraints d'émigrer pour
faire face à la crise ou en allemagne un
des pays les plus durement touchés par
le manque de main d'oeuvre
bérengère d'un glace s'est rendu
outre-rhin
bérengère vous vous êtes rendus en
allemagne et vous pensiez trouvaient
majoritairement des émigrés issus
d'europe de l'est et pourtant ce ne fut
pas le cas oui car l'allemagne a ouvert
ses frontières aux à ces pays qui ont
nouvellement rejoint l'union en mai 2011
il attendait à peu près 150 mille
personnes finalement il y en a que
trente mille qui sont venus en allemagne
alors à cela deux raisons d'abord il ya
plusieurs autres pays européens comme
l'angleterre qui avaient ouvert leurs
frontières bien avant donc les premiers
immigrés sont partis vers ces
destinations la et d'autre part
aujourd'hui les taux de croissance en
pologne lettonie en lituanie sont très
importants donc il ya un différentiel de
niveau de vie qui est pas suffisant pour
tous ces gens aient envie de tout
quitter pour partir en allemagne et donc
du coup vers quel pays les allemands se
sont il tournait alors comme l'allemagne
a besoin de main d'oeuvre
elle a regardé les pays européens qui
avaient des taux de chômage en
augmentation alors c'est le cas de
l'espagne et de la grèce donc c'est
logiquement sur une immigration
intra-européennes que l'allemagne se
tourne donc vous avez été à la rencontre
de meego aller josé à brême
on regarde votre reportage et en sort
perdant suite
voilà quelques semaines que miguel et
josé